mr beast um mr beast is on rogan
and
first of all i didn't know this guy was
23 years old it's crazy it's [ __ ]
crazy he's so impressive so impressive
uh if you guys don't know who mr beast
is he is the number one yeah but if you
didn't know he's the number one youtube
creator in the world i think he's got
between all his accounts over 200
million followers he did this amazing
recreation of the squid game yeah and
that was probably on your radar i think
that was one of the first things not the
first things of him but like one of the
first things that really crossed over
mainstream people who didn't even know
youtube exactly like barely were on it
you heard about it if you know youtube
you're watching us on youtube you see mr
b stuff he does all these amazing
challenges all these incredible videos
racking up 50 million views 100 million
views he he recreates squid game like i
mean builds out the set i think he spent
four million dollars on it it gets more
views than squid game yeah the
recreation of squid game got more views
than squid game which is [ __ ]
unbelievable 229 million views he goes
on more reviews than i think netflix has
subscribers amazing that's right never
because it's like 200 million
subscribers so
he's out there uh he goes on rogan he
has this great conversation on rogan i
haven't finished it just yet but
he is so first of all likable and
endearing incredible man like
he should be
president i swear to god that's the guy
that i'm like this kid should be a
president really yeah i didn't feel that
way at all
i literally didn't get that feeling
at all go ahead he literally says at one
point i didn't even know how to talk to
people yeah yeah he should only be
president if the entire country is just
youtube yeah that's let him be president
of entertainment i don't think he's
gonna want him negotiating like a deal
with iran
oh i think if he if he hyper-obsessed on
geopolitical politics he'd figure this
[ __ ] out oh there you go i agree with
you in that regard he has two things
like i don't understand the point of
getting money to buy a bigger box and
get a bigger but i don't understand the
appeal of that so dumb to me me i want
the bigger box yeah yeah i know i
shouldn't be you haven't gotten robbed
yet
he got robbed and then he was like yeah
and that's what the robbers also felt
you didn't need no no
that's the only reason he moved into a
nicer place is because his expensive
stuff got stolen and then he's like well
i don't need the nicer stuff yeah but i
don't want my software or hardware
whatever the [ __ ] to get stolen yeah so
let's get a nicer place yes but before
that and he can reinvest everything in
the company yes he doesn't care about
any of this [ __ ] he's just hyper
obsessed with with youtube and that's it
yes and that's the kind of guy that i'm
like this is so impressive he's not into
all this other [ __ ] yes he doesn't see
didn't you tell me he took a three-year
valve celibacy yeah i think everything
he said on colin samir he was like yeah
i just hit up my boys and we're like
yeah we're just not dating or having sex
or going after one we're just focused on
this when he's focused on a thing that's
all there is
i love that mine was more you know
involuntary but
i love a person that's like when i set a
goal that's it there's nothing stopping
you yeah yeah maybe think focus young
people are always undefeated like you
like
listening to that episode i saw such a
generational gap between rogan and him
and
like rogan was confused and he was
confused he was confused about rogan's
sort of movie references and rogan was
kind of like confused wait you bought an
island yeah yeah that's my favorite kind
of mutual
one it made me think of like how
antiquated the idea of mainstream media
is as a term
like these are the two biggest media
figures right now right
youtube's a bigger platform than netflix
yes yeah podcasting is a bigger thing
than than television here's the two
titans of this industry and even they
don't have this like shared world view
about the media landscape yeah but when
we think about the future i think it is
people like mr beast just oh
[ __ ] we have young people that can just
figure this out on their own be
completely tied into the analytics get
data back and just grow their audience
reinvest
like it made me very bullish on i bought
more google stock but i heard the
interview yeah it's like
google or youtube already makes more
money than netflix yeah and they got
people like this that they don't have to
risk there's no risk to finding the next
mr beast yeah youtube's not paying him
yeah allowing him yeah and he's coming
up and he's a bigger star than anyone
netflix has yeah they had to lose money
on that stupid leonardo dicaprio movie
just so they could say we have dicaprio
on the platform yeah yeah yeah yeah mr
beast is way bigger
and they didn't pay me anything and he's
like not even in this prime yet yeah
what's that guy going to be doing 10
years from now yeah he's only 23 years
old yeah i mean you got to the part
where you sit every day for a year
basically from like 7 a.m till 10 pm all
he did was study youtube didn't put out
a single thing yeah and he said
something interesting within that was
like him and like four of his friends
yeah and
friends and putting on quotes i guess
he's met these people on the internet
and they basically were just studying
youtube videos what works i think they
look like every youtube video they got
over 10 000 views and they're like why
is this getting more than 10 000 like
how often are they doing angle changes
like dissected every single part of the
video
making process to see like what was
successful and i'm sure they've done
that a million times over but he said
something really interesting he's like
you learn from your failures and let's
say you fail 20 times in a year right
if you have five other friends that are
also creating the same stuff they're
also going to fail 20 times now you and
if you actually share information with
one another you've failed a hundred
times in that one year you've lived five
years of failures in one year yeah so
you're exponentially increasing your
your ability to succeed and it was just
really cool to see him put it like that
think of it as generational evolution
right so like rogan sort of uses youtube
to help blow up his podcast yeah
but he's not really thinking about it
and then you're kind of watching that
and you're using youtube intentionally
to grow your podcast and then you
leverage it and get the sort of show on
netflix and play around and do these
other things he's a generation younger
than you yeah and he's saying like oh
he doesn't want to do a netflix show
yeah youtube is prestige for him whereas
your generation is still a little bit
like we want to use youtube as a as a
tool not as an end goal yes well he's
100 all in because it's like he sees it
as the prestigious platform because
that's all he watched growing up it's
all his friends watched growing up so
his motivations for both growth and
endgame are all tied into one platform
so he has like one target and just like
slams away just hitting that one target
and it's crushing it and to clarify
our position i think that youtube is the
end goal yeah but i recognize that
people my age and around my age
don't realize that yet yeah so doing
something like netflix is like getting
that kind of like blue check because it
allows people around our age to go oh
yeah they're really doing it it's
validation for for people yeah a lot of
people alright you aren't trying to stay
relevant and if those are the rules of
the game not the rules but if that's how
people see stuff and they're hardwired
almost to see it like that you kind of
have to do it in order to take them over
now they see that little validation from
netflix they come to all of our youtube
stuff they go oh this is awesome i love
that oh yeah that's the netflix guy yeah
i love the freedom that his generation
has where they see youtube as the
validator they see a million subscribers
as the validator and they're just like
this is where it is i don't even know
what [ __ ] channel
the abc is on or whatever like this is i
mean that was a change at all for me i
remember my nephew saying i asked him to
put the game on and uh he was like what
channel's on i go abc and he goes what
channel is that yeah yeah young people
are undefeated when it comes to
predicting culture they're always going
to get well they are culture yeah they
drive our culture and they have
unlimited time yeah like if you really
think about it when you're young the
amount you feel like you have so much
responsibility and so much [ __ ] to do
but you're really at school from i don't
know what is it like eight when do you
think it could be 8 a.m to 3 p.m eight
eight three it's eight i was about to
say
i had no [ __ ] clue yeah
no
eight to three right yeah
you're eight to three
there's so much time in the day to just
spend [ __ ] editing doing absolutely
nothing like we spend it playing
football outside of the of my apartment
or like playing basketball do that kind
of [ __ ] but what if editing videos is
your football right like back in the day
editing was so [ __ ] time consuming
dude yeah like i had final cut as a kid
and just waiting for the video tapes to
convert over
it was just forget it it was so much
[ __ ] time now what these kids are
able to do it's unbelievable why would
you not go all in on it
they are and i mean
yeah i mean that's an occupation now
that kids want to be like if you ask
number one right yeah it's like youtuber
is a thing and it blows my mind that you
guys ever had to deal with a generation
where you were a
youtube comedian or that you were a
youtube performer that you were any like
youtubers
like the antecedent for anything or the
president for any word like it's just
insane yeah that was the thing though
youtuber is celebrity the way actor was
celebrity like if you said i want to be
an actor celebrity was just
intrinsically in that youtuber it wasn't
for these kids youtuber intrinsically
means celebrity if you're big enough
like you just assume oh big youtuber
that's a celebrity i really wonder how
many of these celebrity actors now
like how many
outside of maybe the people in euphoria
and even them we can only name a few of
them by name yeah like actors are not
common knowledge yeah isn't that crazy
yeah
no like think about a show
that we're all watching can we name the
actors on the show outside of zendaya
and i don't even know zendaya's last
name and i think she's [ __ ] brilliant
yeah
she goes by zendaya i don't think she
puts it out there okay but yeah
if they've crossed over to movies movies
are still a [ __ ] thing tom holland
zendaya
you know
they're movie stars
are they
marvel movies marvel's a thing
outside i saw batman batman okay but
these are old franchises that we're
bringing up and even the new marvel i
don't even think people are watching
like that
what what movie movie
that is brand new are people going out
for i mean they're still going to see
the rock
like the rock did that thing where he's
on a boat in the jungle jungle boat did
people go see it maybe i don't know i
don't know
like i know the old franchises that are
grandfathered in fast and furious that
kind of stuff yeah people are seeing
that's why they need to reboot because
we're the ones still going to see movies
and they need to appeal to us yeah
jumanji that's familiar i'll go see that
100
that's why they're remaking the same
[ __ ] because it needs to tap into our
nostalgia yeah batman run it back
spider-man run it back don't give me no
new [ __ ] superheroes these kids
aren't gonna go do it yeah they're
watching all their [ __ ] on youtube or uh
what's it called netflix anyway right so
not watching movies is cool i told you
guys yeah i told you it was long enough
i was just starting that i just that's
why i didn't watch movies
in the interview how much validation did
you feel for all the things you picked
finally dude no i don't know i just like
i just love mr beast like his dedication
to it and the fact that he started north
carolina and stays there stayed there
and like they have employees that are
coming from la and new york to north
carolina yeah to just work on what he's
doing and the way that he's masterminded
like all the sets and all the production
like logistically incredible and then
like the way the data powers it it's
just like have you gotten into the food
kitchen and all that [ __ ] yeah i'm
familiar with it but not for me yes he's
a food kitchen that he puts up in cities
that don't necessarily have he says big
cities everybody gets food kitchens in
the basement or every big city is a food
kitchen i go to cities where there's not
a food kitchen necessarily and they
don't have access to it and we feed like
200 people every two weeks 200 families
and we give them good quality food and
then he talked about beast burgers and
his candy bars and he was like i want
them to be healthy nobody's gonna buy
them so i just make them as
not shitty as possible for you but like
to be 23 years old and legitimately
thinking like i don't care about
my personal gain beyond this youtube
thing growing i just want to help as
many people as possible outside of that
it's just [ __ ] it blows me away that
a 23 year old is like that i've never
seen a kid like that in my life maturity
there was something yes joy too yes like
it was all like
that exciting it wasn't like i'm gonna
prove everyone wrong yeah and it was it
it made me hopeful that it wasn't like
that michael jordan motivation yes where
it's like i got chip on my shoulder i'm
a dick to everybody
have to like put my teammates down it
was the exact opposite of that yeah it
was like all i have this awesome team
this person that runs the food kitchen
yeah it's amazing to get a lot of credit
and if if he's like the biggest thing
for that generation on the biggest
platform like
it's [ __ ] great that's great yeah
that's great this is the first time
there's a goat that you're like yo i
want my kid to be like this yeah on and
off the platform of this is what we
wanted child actors to be yes
this is better when we let them figure
it out themselves yeah i also didn't
realize he had crohn's disease yeah
that's the thing he brings up i had no
idea like he has this disease that like
i don't really understand all of it but
like it's basically like an intestinal
issue yeah that like just caused you to
be like lethargic like cause you to have
like intestinal pain like all this all
these things that would you would think
counteract all those stuff he puts out
like the amount of work and time that
goes into creating this stuff
but he just pushes through and doesn't
use that as like uh an adversity he's
overcome he's like yeah it's just this
thing i have
i just thought it was so cool
is he the coolest like normal looking
young person ever
he's not like like logan's kind of like
a big jacked athletic kid he was like
the football player at the high school
yeah
this guy is so kind of just nondescript
unassuming looking yeah yeah yeah and
he's the biggest thing in media so
that's well that's the thing about the
biggest thing in media is so interesting
to me because
to me
he's the biggest thing on youtube but if
you're not on youtube you don't even
know who mr beast is yeah
and the squid game thing was the first
time where i think he crossed over
where i think like traditional media was
doing was having like conversations
about mr beast like if you're in youtube
like us you love this guy this guy's a
genius my parents don't know who he is
my parents are roganists yeah so there
is a threshold
that he would need to cross to become
ubiquitous well i would say the
threshold is if you do have a uh one
version of your show that's four times
bigger than the super bowl an audience
that's the threshold i don't think so
what is it i think it's
i think what happens is eventually the
old people age out and they just die and
then his audience just becomes what
media is
but what's quite interesting is that he
doesn't feel like he needs to jump
outside of the youtube space like he's
all in on the youtube space i'm gonna
create content it's great for youtube
and i'm not gonna he could parody every
big show he could parody euphoria he
could parody every single one and get
crazy views but he's not chasing it and
i think there's something really
interesting about it because if you
notice what happened when he did
something outside the youtube space the
squid game thing was the biggest thing
he's ever done by far yeah yeah right so
what does that mean that means that
people who aren't used to watching him
watched yeah
and
that was the first thing i saw
i remember being i would hear you
talking about him and i assumed it was
some 40 year old kind of douchey guy
calls himself mr beast and i saw this
like adorable kid i was like what the
[ __ ] this is mr beast yeah and that's
how i found out who he was because if
you're not plugged into youtube like i'm
out of touch i have no problem admitting
that and our parents don't give a [ __ ]
about scrolling youtube viewership is so
compartmentalized yes that the biggest
person on youtube can be completely
anonymous to people who aren't watching
youtube that's right and especially
because he's creating content that isn't
based on controversy if you're creating
content around controversy then
naturally like rogan you're going to be
picked up by the mainstream media
they're going to be reacting to your
stuff what is cnn ever going to be upset
about yeah him doing what is fox news
ever going to be upset about him doing
he's not coming out here he's not going
hey these are my views and you should be
uh
judged if you don't uh feel the exact
same way about this issue he's just
going this is going to be the most
watchable thing on the [ __ ] planet
this week and it is yeah
sorry you said something you said
mainstream media and something you
brought up earlier we're the last group
of people that's going to call that
mainstream media yeah it's dead right
yeah it's just that we keep calling it
mainstream media but like he said rogan
gets more views than all the news
networks yep beast gets more views than
every tv show that's ever existed yeah
their mainstream media we just have
these old terms that we've latched on to
yeah mainstream media cnn no it's not
yeah basically just rogan yeah it's your
media's
media legacy media yeah yeah legacy
media and modern media yes those are the
terms yeah because modern media is mr
beast and rogan
you